[Music]
this question is when we get asked
frequently and
i feel for parents i really do
some are concerned that they are being
too strict by not allowing their
children to watch mainstream tv
they ask questions like will putting up
parameters caused my children to rebel
and hey should i let them watch whatever
they want because at least they're doing
it in front of me and not hiding
well there's a lot to unpack here so
let's start with the first part
as a parent are you being too strict by
not allowing your child to watch
mainstream media
well there's a great answer that's found
in proverbs
hear my son and receive my sayings and
the years of your life will be many i
have taught you in the way of wisdom
i have led you in right paths when you
walk your steps will not be hindered and
when you run you will not stumble
take firm hold of instruction do not let
go
keep her for she is your life the whole
point of that message is showing that
children are to heed the words of
parents but within all of that implies a
very profound point
parents are to teach
guide and guard their children
and so from what i see you're perfectly
in line with biblical counsel if you
choose to minimize or even eliminate
mainstream media from your home if
that's what's teaching your children
unbiblical philosophy now comes the big
concern
will putting up those parameters cause
your children to rebel
honestly
it might
i did
being a curious child growing up in a
so-called strict household i did my fair
share of secret watch parties but you
know the truth is we all have sinful
hearts and we just want what we want so
how can you prevent a rebellion for
being fostered within your household
well some of the groundwork should have
been done before this point but there
are also some things that you can do
moving forward let me explain
if you have built up a great
relationship of honesty and trust in
guiding your children so far then they
should know that you have a pretty good
track record of having their best
interests in mind but if you don't have
such a good relationship with your child
well now may be a great time to set a
new foundation so to speak
apologize for your shortcomings share
with them how you're going to do better
going forward and make a conscious
effort to keep your promise and yeah i
know it's humbling
but you expect them to apologize and
right their wrongs
have they ever seen you do it
this is very important it is very
necessary to to foster trust respect and
a good example to your child
so moving forward it's important to keep
the lines of communication open
so before pulling the plug on things
that they really want to watch pray for
the right word so you can explain to
your children yes explain to your
children what you desire for them to do
and why you're doing it
you wanted information when you were
making your choice right well why not
give them that same courtesy after all
they are just miniature versions of you
remember you won't always be with them
to make the decisions for them so now is
the perfect time to help them develop
their reasoning skills have patience and
give them room to ask questions and be
honest about not having all the answers
and for the answers that you do have
hey they may disagree but once you have
that conversation and have expressed
clear boundaries then you will both know
where you as a parent stands
oh
and please please do not forget the love
your children must know that you love
them
because of your love for them
this is why you're giving these
instructions and you got these
instructions from the bible because of
god's love for you
speaking of the bible such a wonderful
and profound book it gives wise counsel
in this regard ephesians chapter 6 verse
4 and you fathers do not provoke your
children to wrath but bring them up in
the training and admonition of the lord
okay let's address that last part should
i let my kids watch whatever they want
because hey at least they're doing it in
front of me and not hiding
well in short
no
let's use a somewhat extreme example
what if they wanted to watch
that oh are we are we not allowed to say
that on youtube anymore
okay well um
fill in whatever extreme case you want
and we'll just
we'll just go with that
so if if that's if it's not okay in that
case then why would it be okay um in the
extremely serious cases of things like
spiritualism or violence or really
anything that's not or goes against
god's ideal
so to summarize all of this
your job as parents is to guide and
instruct your children in the ways of
the lord
but not to force them
into serving the lord
see force is the thing that elicits
these feelings of rebellion and
god doesn't want us to be forced to to
serve him or to have devotion i'm sure
as a parent that may put you in a scary
place a place where the child has to
make your preferred choice on their own
yeah there's risk in that but it's the
same risk that god took when sending his
own son to this earth knowing that
people would reject him
now many have found solace in this bible
promise found in isaiah chapter 49 verse
25 but thus says the lord even the
captives of the mighty shall be taken
away and the prey of the terrible be
delivered for i will contend with him
who contends with you and i will save
your children
we appreciate those who have been
vulnerable with us in sending your
questions
and really you're literally the reason
that this series continues on so if
you're interested in contacting us all
that information is in the description
of this video and if this video was at
all helpful to you please leave a like
it helps with the algorithm so this
video gets recommended to other people
so thank you in advance and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you